well my city tonight is really sad still
shocked but i'm also really amazed about
the dignity of the people of Paris and
how they've been like reacting in
solidarity and on they are standing
saying we are not afraid we are outside
we're having drinks on the terrace and
we just life is gonna go on also people
were just letting off like balloons I
think we can possibly see when they're
going up in the sky one of the things
that has struck me about the reaction of
the people I've been talking to what
I've been seeing in the French media is
the fact that it just was so
indiscriminate what happened that it was
just so criminal in Skrim indiscriminate
yeah and targeting young people it was
really i mean obvious of what the e de
islamic state's wants to do it was like
shutting to the young people the people
who are having fun or having drinks to
partying and just like the real nice
Paris the Paris of liberty of freedom
that was a shot so it's not a pie Ezard
that that had that happened there but
then I think it's really a really bad
mistakes as well because then it was all
the people of Harrison or all the people
of carrot Paris even more strongly
linked together and standing in front of
that anyone have heard but the US
Secretary of State just put the speaking
in Paris saying that this conflict is
not about a clash of civilizations it's
about is who are against all
civilization I've never been keen on the
civilization theory that I know it we've
been hearing for such a long time and
i'll never be i think this is something
about integrase extremist crazy and our
world our society so it has nothing to
do on the water civilization is just
about democracy and defending our values
and the strong values that Frances
actually represent
inevitably people are fearful of another
attack you have to any major attacks in
Paris this year what needs to change in
your society to think
well actually what is I mean what we
what we had to this days in Paris is
really like a turning point I have to
say and unfortunately we are expecting
something else to happen and I think we
have too many issues on which we have to
work is even much more solidarity
building the community in Paris here
it's something really mayor dalga wants
to strike zone in the next year but it
was already a job we had to do and then
it to do on the international affair and
that is to on the state level should be
down and I really hope that the next day
we'll show a large and a wide coalition
to find five days extremism the
president told politicians today MPs
from Parliament that he wanted to extend
the state of emergency for three months
what does that mean in practice well
that states means that we gonna we have
special measure from the states meaning
the police has a specific action
different things like implication on the
Undercity right now this has to be
discussed by the bathtub the provider
Parliament discussion in the next days
to see ya how is going to be the balance
between that state of emergency and the
need for individual liberties to be
maintained this is something people in
France cares a lot about so now the
French president has to show why and how
we're gonna make that and then the
parliaments gonna decide I mean as the
deputy mayor of Paris do you think you
need three months of state of emergency
at jacia well actually I'm not that sure
actually I really understood that the
president took the decision there for
the 12 days now that we are in the state
of emergency because it was such a crazy
situation that we had to cope with to
cope with security to cope with the
security of the people of Paris but I
think life also has to go on in Paris
and people of cars are really ready to
take it on so let's see let's see what
is real
the deal proposed by the president in
the next days we never to be there has
been some disruption to Paris today
streets closed that kind of thing there
are some disruption but there are not as
the ones sometimes the TV is also
described because I've been outside from
Saturday on yes life is quietly quiet
than the crater them than the other days
life has was going to take time to go
back to normal that's really true we had
some disruption on the transportation
but scenes from this morning on schools
were open all the public services were
open people are coming back in the
streets so yeah it's a huge it's a big
event but life is going really quickly
on